1er juin 1969 premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle la scp you l'ancêtre du
parti socialiste réalise son pire score
sous la vème république
son candidat gaston defferre arrive à la
quatrième place avec 20 % des suffrages
comment expliquer ce résultat retour un
mois plus tôt le 4 mai 1969 les
socialistes sont réunis en congrès à
alfortville au programme un une volonté
de ressouder la gauche leur défaite aux
législatives un an plus tôt a laissé des
traces de la désignation du candidat à
l'élection présidentielle anticipée
après la démission du général de gaulle
[Musique]
victoire à la majorité mais sans trop d
fusion pour gaston defferre et pour
cause les débats pour une candidature
unique à gauche ont été houleux je pense
que j'ai la fana campagne électorale
ainsi que les jambes pour le candidat de
gauche dans une bonne situation une
bonne situation pas sur le candidat de
gauche ne fait pas l'unanimité auprès
des divers courants socialistes et des
communistes
la gauche est éclatée résultat les
candidatures à la présidentielle se
multiplient l'objectif il est de
parvenir à une expression commune de la
solution socialiste pour ce pays
n'aspirent est un président citoyens à
l'image de ce pays j'aspire à être un
véritable arbitre seulement soucieux
d'apporter la liberté et la justice pour
tous c'est dans ces conditions que le
comité central de notre parti a décidé
ma candidate pour la première fois un
militant révolutionnaire à la
possibilité de s'exprimer devant vous la
division à gauche est telle que certains
appellent même à voter pour le candidat
centriste alain power dès le premier
tour
face à cette désunion des personnalités
réagissent et appelle à une candidature
unique parmi elles l'auteur jean ferrat
le comédien jean vilar et l'écrivain
georges conchon une fraction de la
gauche a tenu entre ses mains la plus
grande chance de toute la gauche depuis
15 ans
nous savons que des millions de français
sont comme nous accabler par le
spectacle qu'elle a donnée par son refus
d'entendre les appels à l'unité qui lui
venaient du plus grand nombre l'appel ne
sera pas entendue la bataille se jouera
donc dans les urnes et pour les
socialistes elle sera dévastatrice
gaston defferre et éliminé dès le 1er
tour avec 5 % des suffrages très loin
derrière le communiste jacques duclos
créditée de 20% des suffrages
[Musique]